monday is the final call for russian
airlines to hand back hundreds of
commercial aircraft to their foreign
owners eu sanctions mean that leasing
companies have had to cancel their
contracts to supply russian carriers
with planes now at least planes make up
the majority of the western-built
commercial jets used by russian airlines
there are more than 500 of them with a
combined total of some 10 billion
dollars now while these planes have been
unable to fly outside of russia because
of sanctions banning them from european
airspace many are still flying domestic
routes and lessers are losing hope of
actually getting them back russia's
transportation minister says the kremlin
will compensate owners for their
aircraft but they've reportedly been no
negotiations so far because any
agreement would breach sanctions well
let's get to the bottom of this story by
speaking to aviation journalist andreas
spade thanks for joining us on dw
business
what chance have these lessors got of
actually getting these planes back
they're actually quite slim at the
moment as it seems and interestingly one
has to know that just physically
reclaiming the aircraft themselves
doesn't really solve the whole problem
because if they stay on in russia for
some time now and maybe hand it over in
some period of time from now they might
be worthless and the reason is that
aircraft maintenance records are
absolutely decisive for any aircraft and
if the lessers don't know what has been
done to the aircraft while they were
stuck in russia they are really
worthless for the listers after taking
them back without documentation that's a
very major point to observe here
and one of the things that the russian
government's done to try and get around
this is to
recertify the jets or re-register them
in
russia is that is that something they
can do is that legal
yes it is because bermuda where for tax
reasons most of the western russian
aircraft fleet had been registered so
far actually dropped them from the
register as part of the sanctions so
there was actually a need to re-register
them and but still experts call this the
biggest theft in history because some of
them even estimate the worth of the like
523 aircraft that we are talking about
at the moment up to 12 billion u.s
dollars and so the lasers are actually
unable to retrieve them for example for
probably very very anytime soon so it
might be really considered a theft and
while registering or brilliant string is
kind of a legal thing the problem is
also the sanctions um
don't allow any maintenance like western
spare parts can't be taken to russia
yeah so essentially these planes are
going to become unusable aren't they if
they can't be maintained so it would
appear that russia is heading for a
shortage
of airplanes how do they get around that
i mean of course they can fly them for
sometimes domestic wood is a huge
country with a big domestic market it
was even fairly doing fairly well before
covert uh i mean
like before kobe already within the
pandemic and even before the war started
the russian domestic market worked quite
well so they could use this aircraft for
some time they could also cannibalize
some of the aircraft stuck in russia to
maintain others with the parts but that
would be a violation of international
aviation regulations also people really
say this is a fundamental breach this
whole thing of the 1944 chicago
convention which really is underlying
all kinds of aviation since 1944. so
it's really uncharted territory here it
really is isn't it well andreas spade
thanks for trying to guide us through
that territory
thank you
you